[Musique]
une course mémorable c'est un extrait du
livre
maxime laope un chanteur populaire écrit
par et 10 expedite laub cerneaux est un
adepte guillou donc une course mémorable
après les chevaux c'est lé bourrique qui
courait j'ai participé deux fois à ces
courses là j'avais un copain qui
travaillait pour le directeur de la
société des courses tous les deux on a
cherché une bourrique pour que je puisse
participer aux courses mon copain
faisant le palefrenier
on a convaincu quelqu'un de nous prêter
sa bête pour la course mais elle posait
problème
elle n'avait pas de brides j'ai dû me
contenter de la longue corde avec
laquelle elle était attachée
c'était une bête pas du tout prête à
faire une course n était pas seul et je
les monte comme ça sans rien elle était
tellement maigre que ces os ça y est et
que ça m'a coupé les fesses je n'ai pas
fait une course mais un numéro de cirque
les quatre autres bourrique ont couru
normalement mais la mienne
elle a d'abord commencé à trottiner sur
la piste mais dès qu'elle a vu la route
qui conduisait chez elle elle a voulu à
tout prix la prendre et quitter la piste
non pas le froid nier était bien embêté
et moi aussi
faisant tout pour essayer de maintenir
sur la piste cette bourrique qui
s'efforçait de prendre le chemin qu'ils
allaient vers l'église de la délivrance
le public passion a attendu l'arrivée du
dernier c'était moi je suis arrivé en
faisant le pitre pour faire rire le
public
j'ai fait sauter mamou rick sur une
planche je lui ai fait faire quelques
cabrioles et je suis descendu en dansant
le séga autour de l'animal tout le monde
était pliée de rire
le titre une course mémorable une course
mémorable
à la ligne après les chevaux après les
chevaux après les chevaux virgules
c'est lé bourrique qui courait c'était
c'était les burritos les bourrique qui
courait c'était laid bourrique qui
courait points j'ai participé deux fois
à ces courses là j'ai participé j'ai
participé deux fois deux fois à ces
courses là a fait course
là point de suspension
à la ligne j'avais un copain
j'avais j'avais un copain copain qui
travaillait pour qui travaillait pour le
directeur de la société des courses
pour le directeur
pour le directeur de la société de la
société des courses des courses
point
tous les deux tous les deux tous les
deux virgules
on a cherché une bourrique
on a cherché on a cherché une bourrique
une bourrique pour que je puisse
participer pour que je puisse participer
pour que je puisse participer aux
courses aux courses pour que je puisse
participer ou course virgules
mon copain faisant le palefrenier mon
copain mon copain faisant faisant le
palefrenier le palefrenier points
22 la dictée pour les cm1 voilà on
dépose le style au lycée aime bien et on
est sage comme vous l'êtes depuis tantôt
nous continuons avec tous les autres à
la ligne on a convaincu quelques uns on
a convaincu
on a convaincu quelqu'un quelqu'un de
nous prêter sa bête de nous prêter de
nous prêter sa bête
sa bête pour la course pour la course
virgules
mais elle posait problème mais mais elle
posait problème
elle posait problème
deux points elle n'avait pas de brides
elle n'avait pas de brides elle n'avait
pas deux brides virgules
j'ai dû me contenter 2 j'ai dû j'ai dû
me contenter me contenter de la longue
corde de la longue corde de la longue
corde avec laquelle avec laquelle
elle était attachée elle était attachée
elle était attachée points fin de la
dictée pour les cm2 à la ligne c'était
une bête
c'était une bête
c'était une bête pas du tout prête à
faire une course pas du tout prête pas
du tout prête à sem à faire une course
bien lieu
elles n'étaient pas scellées elles
n'étaient pas scellées elles n'étaient
pas scellées virgules
je les monte comme ça je lai montée je
l' ai monté comme ça comme ça virgule
sans rien sans rien sans rien point elle
était tellement maigre que elle était
elle était tellement maigre que
[Musique]
tellement maigre que ces eaux
ça y est que ces eaux
ça y est et et que ça m'a coupé les
fesses que ça m'a coupé que ça m'a coupé
les fesses les faits ce point
fin de la dictée pour les 6e nous
continuons à la ligne je n'ai pas fait
une course je n'ai pas fait une course
je n'ai pas fait une course virgule mais
un numéro de cirque mais met un numéro
de cirque un numéro de cirque points les
quatre autres bourrique ont couru
normalement les quatre les quatre autres
bourrique autres bourrique les quatre
autres bourrique ont couru normalement
ont couru normalement points mais la
mienne mais la mienne points de
suspension point d'exclamation
mais la mienne points de suspension
point d'exclamation à la ligne
elle a d'abord commencé à trottiner
elle a d'abord commencé
elle a d'abord commencé à trottiner sur
la piste
la piste de virgules
mais dès qu'elle a vu la route qui
conduisait chez elle
mais dès qu'elle a vu la route dès
qu'elle a vu la route qui conduisait
chez elle qui conduisait chez elle
via bull elle a voulu elle a voulu elle
a voulu à tout prix la prendre à tout
prix la prendre et quitté la piste à
tout prix la prendre et quitter la piste
et quitter la piste points
fin de la dictée pour les cinquièmes à
la ligne mont pas le freigné était bien
embêté mon palefrenier était bien embêté
mon palefrenier était bien embêté
virgule et moi aussi
et moi aussi
point
non excusez moi vous mettrez une virgule
je reprends la phrase mon palefrenier
était bien embêté virgule et moi aussi
virgule faisant tout pour essayer de
maintenir sur la piste faisant tout
faisant tout pour essayer pour essayer
de maintenir sur la piste de maintenir
sur la piste virgule 7 bourrique qui
s'efforçait de prendre le chemin
cette bourrique 7 bourrique qui s'est
forcé qui s'efforçait de prendre de
prendre le chemin de prendre le chemin
qu'ils allaient vers l'église de la
délivrance qui allaient qui allait vers
l'église vers l'église de la délivrance
de la délivrance points
à la ligne le public le public virgules
action patients virgule a attendu
l'arrivée du dernier le public virgule
patients virgule a attendu l'arrivée du
dernier deux points
c'était moi c'était moi point
d'exclamation fin de la dictée pour les
quatrièmes à la nuit je suis arrivé en
faisant le pitre
je suis arrivé en faisant le pitre pour
faire rire le public pour faire rire le
public points
j'ai fait sauter ma bourrique sur une
planche
planche virgules je lui ai fait faire
quelques cabrioles
je lui ai fait faire quelques cabrioles
et je suis descendu et je suis descendu
en dansant le séga en dansant le séga
autour de l'animal autour de l'animal
point tout le monde était pliée de rire
tout le monde était plié de vire
point final
reprenez vos copies les petits tout le
monde reprend sa copie parce que je vais
relire une fois le texte si jamais vous
avez oublié un mot raté quelque chose
c'est le moment ou jamais d'accord une
course mémorable
après les chevaux c'étaient les
bourrique qui courait j'ai participé
deux fois à ces courses là
j'avais un copain qui travaillait pour
le directeur de la société des courses
tous les deux on a cherché une bourrique
pour que je puisse participer aux
courses mon copain faisant le
palefrenier
on a convaincu quelqu'un de nous prêter
sa bête pour la course mais elle posait
problème
elle n'avait pas de brides j'ai dû me
contenter de la longue corde avec
laquelle elle était attachée
c'était pas c'était une bête pas du tout
prête à faire une course
elles n'étaient pas scellées je les
monte comme ça sans rien elle était
tellement maigre que ces hausses ier et
que ça m'a coupé les fesses je n'ai pas
fait une je n'ai pas fait une course
mais un numéro de cirque
les quatre autres mouric ont couru
normalement mais la mienne
elle a d'abord commencé à trottiner sur
la piste mais dès qu'elle a vu la route
qui conduisait chez elle elle a voulu à
tout prix la prendre et quitter la piste
mon palefrenier était bien embêté et moi
aussi
faisant tout pour essayer
maintenir sur la piste cette bourrique
qui s'efforçait de prendre le chemin
qu'ils allaient vers l'église de la
délivrance le public passion a attendu
l'arrivée du dernier c'était moi je suis
arrivé en faisant le pitre pour faire
rire le public
j'ai fait sauter ma bourrique sur une
planche
je lui ai fait faire quelques cabrioles
et je suis descendu en dansant le séga
autour de l'animal tout le monde était
pliée de rire
[Musique]